Jesus Christ how's it going citizens of the reject
Nation John here for another solo movie reaction
and this is what I've been looking forward to
for a long time because uh as many of you know
but some of you probably don't over on patreon we
cover a bunch of TV shows and movies and whatnot
and a lot of that stuff is Anime related or
at least a good you know sort of section of
it is dedicated to anime and this was a show
that I've been following for the first season
took a break when the season ended and since have
been you know sort of occupied with a whole bunch
of other things and it's taken me a while to get
to this point but it was always part of the plan
to check out Mugen train the hit the Smash Hit
Demon Slayer movie um this is a bit of a risk
because as you'll notice we don't really cover a
ton of anime here on YouTube it's a pretty tricky
process and we have received copyright strikes in
the past for attempting to do so which take six
months or more to get removed from your account
they can be a big pain in the behind and so uh
this video in and of itself is a bit of a risk
so if you're seeing it that means we did it so
leave a like while you can that would be very
much appreciated helps out the channel leave
a comment uh with your thoughts or anything that
you feel the need to correct me on or enlighten me
about there's probably going to be a few of those
moments as well don't forget to subscribe to the
channel hit that notification Bell so you can keep
track of anything and everything we have coming
out that you might be interested in and of course
as I mentioned before if you want to get the full
experience with me come on over to patreon.com the
real rejects bring your own copy sync up with the
time code get the complete experience plus check
out all of our other shows and movies that we have
over their music videos and such we got reaction
highlights as well as full-length watch alongs
for a bunch a bunch of that stuff and last but
certainly not least thank you to the team over
at prepper for doing the reaction highlights on
this video on countless other videos across the
channel they are hugely hugely instrumental in
everything you see before you in these reaction
videos so uh much much love to prepper and without
further Ado I got my muzon kibutsuji hat right
here ready to go it's definitely going to stay on
for the entire video just you watch let's do this
so beautiful God
just like the whole artwork on this show all the
environments and stuff like is absolutely gorgeous
foreign
come on kids hop aboard
lens flare like all the subtle flourishes
someone's getting a model trained for Christmas
because I'm about to save your
asses from demons in a few minutes
it's literally the least I could do
you recognize his hair yeah see
man
I gotta watch a whole making of just on
how they do these kinds of shots like wow
who might
you might no uh hey there
foreign
um foreign
yeah this guy's dead man this
guy's like rotting already
wasting no time boy
oh foreign
Wowie
that was awesome bro
oh now you want to be The Apprentice
oh look at those two both of those two
oh dude
oh
what's up
oh so twisted
samurita
oh buddy
cool man
you know this is a sound effect s
so nasty but so cool
kids Monica
uh little do you know
thank you thank you
of course the mighty train it's
a mighty trained to peed okay
this is definitely my favorite dream
s
Jesus thank you for the encouragement dad
um
foreign
oh that's messed up it's very creatively messed up
um
oh wow
oh damn
oh no still a child but but oh no
oh I'm so conflicted right now
realize it
oh
foreign just jump off of something High
Jesus mythical
my true form
foreign
memories
oh hardest steps you have to take it
you've been waiting around a
little bit my dude no to you
meanwhile in the opposite of that
yeah you picked the wrong
person's mind to invade foreign
yes you have to grope him specifically
laughs
of course his subconscious would be
like shrewd that way because that makes a lot
of sense that the way zenitsu channels his power
children
oh geez
wake up
oh no foreign
foreign
chooses truth
oh here it comes
oh nice foreign
they're so good at depicting
that like careening motion
excuse oh my God this is
Live Die repeating over here
yeah I mean my dude can't be
afraid of much now foreign
foreign
this is a dream yeah I was
about to say it was too easy
oh what the [__]
got all that joking up at the front
actually it wasn't too far off
it's like the blob
thank you foreign
explosive Awakening
sweetness me foreign
just looking at this I'm
like I bet that smells awful
this whole thing must feel would
smell like sweat and viscera and decay
it's all the more disturbing to
think that they're actually inside of
this demon who's now become like a flesh tube
oh yeah yeah see what nezuko can do with this
God this is like Resident Evil Zero
yeah buddy that's so cool
I like that no matter how dejected he
gets has always got that confident smile
that was a hospital my friend in action
s the yellow boy careful there is
foreign
that is too many hands foreign
I like that Tundra gets him enough to just
be like sure okay you're the leader whatever
oh it's it's [__] up spinal column
ugh
oh wow
okay
there's got to be a way to
practice like tunnel vision
oh Daniel this is
I bet that mask is helping out
wow
that's so cool
God how much matter does this
demon have at its disposal
like a whack-a-mole
oh geez
whoa no oh
beautiful
oh
what the most selfless if I die then that guy
will be a murderer and I don't want that for him
foreign
oh no who is this like the
bottom of the upper upper three
he's here to [__] [__] up dog
oh
that bisect oh
that's like saw five
foreign
I can tell we have no common interests
I like this rangoku quite a bit
jeez there's an ultimatum for you oh oh damn
that's cool
they could
oh my God
CQC
s
thank you cousin of Stephen blazing universe
oh I'm starting to get nervous
oh my God
total concentration breathing man
foreign
ER
disorder
no yeah
I don't think so nope yeah oh damn it oh
that like warping effect on the sides
of the screen that like lensing thing
there's that spirit in the face
yeah you are
oh cool oh my God
oh the twist
Jesus ah
huh it's like a it's like a mushroom cloud
um
words to live by
e
foreign
no you don't
tightening all of his abs around your arm yoga
yeah not so tough now are you not so tough at dawn
Move Your Body
no get grab him
don't be a [__]
clearly ready for the sun yeah
I ate something
ah you're just rational like
you're just bargaining dude
oh dude
yeah and don't you forget it foreign
mama
foreign
you can like see the sunlight
shining through his skin
foreign foreign
Focus pulling
oh what a gorgeous shot
I mean
be at peace
oh and that's okay
oh
dude
my eyes are sweating
God and he's just still sitting there Jesus
look how torn up the ground is
wow what a note to end on I mean obviously you
know there's gonna be more but still interesting
like somber tone to leave off on makes it feel
like the whole movie is dedicated to him Goku
yeah they get good music for these man these
themes are rousing it's a very cool character I
mean you know like we met him briefly in the first
season I feel like and then you know to really I
mean in a lot of ways this is kind of his movie
I mean tundra and Company certainly are on the
journey certainly have a lot to learn but like I
feel like he is the centerpiece he is the the sort
of core soul of this movie and it's like the the
top ranking guy like just tore through the veil
of everything we'd the whole situation we'd just
been in with uh you know lower one or whatever
that was and uh he pierced his uh he pierced
the core of his soul and it's interesting too
the way that these songs I mean I'm sitting here
watching the credits and they're like lyrics but
it's interesting the way that these songs re like
they go out of their way I I feel like in a more
direct sense than we do here with various things
to like really make sure that the themes of the
music match the themes of what you're watching
there's a lot of perseverance and there's a lot
of grappling with grief you know appealing to
the strength deep within I feel like that's a
it's a heavy theme in a lot of anime things and
especially here is the sort of dig deep you know
like what does it take to dig deep what is your
motivation for digging deep what Touchstone can
you call upon loved his sword too I mean his whole
look is great like I I like the designs of the
hashira and the demons too I mean like the designs
of everything are really gorgeous in this show but
yeah like to spend so much time with the flame
hashira and to have you know all these different
just like you know the design of his whole his
eyes the color of his eyes you know the different
uh Shades in his hair the hilt of the sword and
everything all right that's all she wrote Let's
chitty chat about it all right my friends we did
it we did it we rode the Mugen train at long last
uh you know it's it's almost funny to be here now
after so much time and thinking back on the early
stages of the pandemic when this movie was like
tearing up the box office when there was literally
almost no box office to tear up uh but yeah man I
had a great time with this I really enjoyed this
I mean I feel like one of the first questions
that comes to anyone's mind when you're dealing
with an anime movie or a movie based on anything
that you know is from an episodic format to one
degree or another I feel like the the question
looms is it just like one long episode or does
it really feel like a movie and I think this
movie did a nice job at at least Bridging the
Gap and and kind of coming towards the middle of
that for me I mean I feel like you know looking
at the show and from what I understand this is
like the first chunk of season two is like a
semi-expanded version of this which I find almost
better ironic that there is you know that this
movie can be seen in an elongated form as if a
movie wasn't the whole kind of place to do that
um and as such I mean I am curious to know what
was taken out and what will be added back by that
experience and hey if anybody is a patron and and
you know I imagine we will continue with season
two uh let me know what you want to see if you
want to see you know uh those episodes again with
all that added context or if I should just you
know watch the first episode and then catch up
with the rest of my own time until it's new stuff
and then go from there but that's a sidebar um but
yeah you know like it's interesting because you
know to know that this does exist in the episodic
format with I'm sure some of the flourishes that
are unique to that uh you know side of the medium
uh I thought this did again nicely to justify
itself as a movie I'm kind of torn actually I mean
I feel like you know in some ways knowing how arcs
on Demon Slayer are uh you know this definitely
feels like it I could easily see how you could
dice this up and make this Arc a compilation
however uh I thought this as a story for the movie
theaters was nice because it you know hones in on
the core of these characters and in a way it is
very much urengoku or kyojiro's movie you know I
mean so much of the focus is on him we're meeting
him ostensibly at least intimately for the first
time we've seen him in the past you know we we've
got a taste of them but this is the first time
we're really like spending with him and I feel
like there is a tendency at least thinking back
on some of the other like anime spin-off movies
that we've seen you know to kind of highlight a
side or a sort of spoken of character and make it
yeah a vignette mostly about them for the main Arc
of the story but then also you know showing how it
enhances the journeys of our uh Heroes who are you
know gonna be the through lines of the show and
whatnot and as such I mean I got really pulled
into his story and I really liked the uh Motif the
device of the dreams and that was something that
felt kind of especially cinematic like I really
enjoyed the way at the outset you know you meet
him he's eating the food delicious you know it's
like a quirky situation picking up from right
where we left off at the end of uh season one with
them on the train main platform you know evading
the police and then you know you get right into
this demon fight and uh you know as first it's
like okay we're wasting no time you know they
hey they Triumph and then they all take a nap
and everything's great and of course you know
it's a little too easy and then you break into
um this motif of the dreams which makes way for
a lot of fun and games and a lot of imaginative
you know chaos and craziness and disturbing
imagery that that anime is so good at delivering
um but it also you know is tied into the roots
of the characters and it's also revealing of
the characters and I appreciated that we saw you
know this glimpse into uh uh kyojiro's past uh
but through the the lens of this dream so that you
can't a hundred percent tell if it's even real per
se but it is indicative of you know what's truly
inside and I like that you know even though you
have this really dejected moment this really
discouraging moment between uh kyodro and his
father I'm gonna use his names interchangeably so
I hope no one gets confused but yeah like seeing
this this heart crunching moment where he's like
I've made it to this you know huge milestone I
am you know the flame hashira you know I achieved
you know one of the highest achievements you know
that that I could have you know and his father's
like you know I don't think it's gonna make a
difference you're not I don't make a difference
you don't make a difference I don't really care
you know and it's so heart heart-rending and it
informs so much of the rest of the movie because
then you get those subsequent moments showing
the love from his mother and you know that bond
that really fills that void left by his father
and also the way he seeks to empower his little
brother like his dream in tanjiro's dream are
are quite similar I feel like uh in that yeah
they're they're both at home and they're both you
know with the realities and and some of the more
um I don't know like uh idealized aspects of their
lives back at home and I love how he empowers his
little brother he says you know even though hey
Dad wasn't receptive to what I just told him at
all you know like I'm still really proud of you
and you know no matter what you choose to do with
your life I'm going to be supporting you and
we together you know even if we're apart we're
going to achieve like that was really lovely
and then to see that transfer onto tanjiro and
zenitsu and inasuke through this experience and
and despite their initial reluctance I think was
really nice and a lot of fun and by the end it's
funny me and I was like I wanted the tears I was
almost there I really really really was moved by
The End by his journey and again like they're so
good at doing that in anime especially and and
you know a lot of Shonen has those recurring
themes of perseverance and sort of confronting
and embracing your core traumas and using them
as fuel to push yourself past your limits and to
achieve and so yeah like by the end I just really
love that brotherly Bond and the way he takes
them under his wing and the way that you can
tell that his quirkiness while funny and and kind
of odd is built on something real it's like he's
unflappable well he's determined he's a little
above it all but in a sense it makes sense and
he does you know manage to raise each of you know
our heroes up with that and uh and yeah I like the
way that he and tanji are like there's that whole
thing about like you know the the water hashira
and the fire hashira like side by side and even
though you know right now it's not like official
even though it's whatever he said it's been like
so long since that's been the case that there have
been you know but one of each side by side you
know as a member as members you know of the main
you know active hashira uh getting to see them
together and getting to see tanjiro switch back
and forth between his water breathing techniques
as well as the flame techniques like was really
really gratifying and then you know you see uh uh
kyojiro setting the example just with again that
being his expertise um but again like even the use
of the elements I mean there's so many beautiful
and amazing looking fire effects and I really like
that yeah it's like as you're exploring everyone's
dream you're getting a glimpse into how they see
life and what's valuable to them and I really like
the mechanics of how the dreams worked I thought
this had a really nice grip on that too where yeah
they have these fantasies that people were lulled
into and and people want to believe in some kind
of idealized fantasy but it's not infinite and
beyond that you know barrier or the periphery
The Edge is you know basically their subconscious
where the essence of their soul is and so yeah I
love that that dividing line between like if you
just kill yourself in the dream or you get killed
in the dream and you're just in the bubble you'll
you'll probably just wake up and you're fine but
yeah if somebody really pierces beneath to the
to the core of your soul like it's a cool astral
concept and uh and yeah the way they realize that
for everybody I thought was really nice because
yeah you get obviously a nosuke like you know are
mostly supporting humorous bad at like they're
here to provide humor and badassness in this movie
they don't get much in terms of the character meat
or growth which is fine because I really enjoyed
both of their moments I mean zinitsu always cracks
me up with his like cowardly Antics although here
I mean was more badass than itsu uh you know more
just of him in the trance and I appreciate again
the way that they're able to expand on and justify
things like that because in a breath as much as
I enjoy it it is like man this guy is like in his
waking form just so so so so so so so ill-suited
to this and yet yeah when he blacks out he is just
deadly and I loved that you know based on what
we know about his backstory and his training and
everything his subconscious is essentially just
this darkened void with no anything like no even
Echoes of love just him you know it's it's almost
it's the opposite of the coward on the inside it's
the on edge like paranoid like nobody's supposed
to be in here except for desuko and of course
he's chasing as it go around and nezuko too I mean
like she gets accepted by the end which I really
appreciated and even though nobody's gonna hear
that uh you know it was very gratifying to have
her join in the fight you know just continue on
her mission of protecting any and all humans and
you know being in major asset in terms of fighting
with the actor demons but yeah like that was very
gratifying and yeah just to see into especially
tanjiro's dreams because we spent you know the
most time there and again man like the way that
they capture the elements like I love the the
prologue and the epilogue to this movie and that's
another thing that made it feel very cinematic was
having these somber tones to begin and end the
movie the toll it's like we're going to see a lot
of badass demon fighting obviously and we're gonna
see some crazy blood demon art and we're gonna see
some crazy imaginative stuff but at the beginning
and end it's really honed in on the toll and I
liked that um I always forget uh uh oyakatasama
there you go I always that's one of the ones I
I have to commit full on to memory but yeah um
I really like that they start with him being
reflective and I mean he's dying he's got this
you know corrosive disease and uh he's reflecting
on the fact that yeah like you know they're
more demon attacks and you know so many people
are going out there and fighting and dying for
this in this Mission with the train as we later
find out has swallowed up so many people and so
many demon Slayers and you know just feeling the
weight of that and the way that which you know
he feels obviously like he is the sort of guiding
force of this and as such you know people are
sort of fighting a communal battle but his battle
certainly as it is organized here and yeah to
have him feeling that toll as a father would his
children he's sending off to war essentially like
I really like that tone and then coming to the end
where like even as uh uh uh kyojiro is is bleeding
out on the ground he still finds the smile and
he still finds the means to you know encourage
tanjiro and the others to go on and you know even
despite you know the toll and even despite what's
hard about it and I love that it all culminates uh
with lower three because two I mean what this is
doing for the show is uh is setting up you know
the the 12 kizuki even that much more we've seen a
couple of them up until now and those have always
been really striking really unique uh battles and
with you know very interesting motifs and whatnot
but uh yeah here I feel like we're showing okay so
once we get to the to the top of the lower ranks
basically it released the remaining lower ranks we
see just how formidable that can be but then you
also set the stage for the upper ranks and just
how much more impossible that seems and so yeah as
the Journey of kyojiro through this and ultimately
meeting this match of like one of the you know
elitists of the elite villains like I thought that
story was really satisfying and really nicely done
and again like our heroes are more apprentices
through that but it does again touch on the
core of their journey and the mortality that they
face all the time and yeah like kyojiro represents
something that I think all of them don't have I
mean for tundra it's like having a brother figure
who is like familial and who can impart with
who can be like a mentor in that way it's like
his dream takes him back to his family to being
at home to the simple life to what he should be
doing despite all of this but what he cannot uh
you know lull into what he can't go back to and
what he can't hold on to so strongly that he's you
know not able to move forward and uh you know you
have such these warm little tones with that and
uh and it it highlights that contrast and then
yeah you have kyojiro to kind of fill that in
in the president even though you know it's very
painful at the end like everybody cries because
everybody was touched by this guy and yeah like
zinitsu and and uh in usuke too like the the the
traumas and the and the you know loneliness and
um you know this sort of ostracization that's
a random ass word but yeah like the ways in
which they've been shunned in the past they all
have a reason to gravitate towards this guy and
especially after that initial display of uh you
know demons slaying where they're all just so
enamored like yeah it was nice to see them all
really uh get at least a little bit of emotional
uh sort of fill up from that because yeah when
it comes right down to it like I like that you
have this this double this two-fold approach from
the demons like with uh I think his name emu uh uh
you know upper or lower one uh you know his whole
thing about like you know humans are selfish and
they want to you know believe in you know these
one uh these very satisfying fantasies and and
that's the perfect way to slip away in a delusion
that is pleasant and you know it won't even matter
I'm doing you a favor this is going to be nice and
and you can see like I love that too are they kids
or are they adults the people who are you know
like tying them up with the ropes and even that I
thought was like a cool Motif to get them you know
into the dreams so that they can you know break in
and do the damage they have to do and uh yeah just
like that whole idea that people willingly go that
way and then watching as each of our characters
core motivations arise I mean yeah we get those
glimpses into their subconsciousness um but each
of them you know does it a different way it's like
in usuke he just like runs the whole Onslaught
off like you picked with the rock dude wrong
dream uh and you know eventually is is woken up
by nezuko but yeah he puts up a strong fight and
zinitsu obviously is like very disconcerting in
the way only he could be but I love the contrast
with tanjiro the way he leads the guy to it and
basically with compassion and love shows him the
fragility and the beauty of the thing he's about
to destroy and he overcomes the guy with emotion
and he truly like cured he doesn't just like fight
the guy off he like kind of cures something within
that guy that that you know uh left him vulnerable
to this fiendish want for the sleep for the dream
for the escape from his real circumstances the
tuberculosis or whatever that was and then yeah
to bring that you know for them to Vanquish uh you
know this this crazy you know dream inducing train
villain and of course you get your Kaiju Battle
with your crazy ass eyes I really like the body
horror stuff with that character in particular and
it's interesting too I mean this show obviously
has a lot of cutting edge blending of drawn
animation and CG animation and I'm always there
are always things I really appreciate about it and
they're always things that I feel like we're not
quite a hundred percent seamless with yet but
I mean this is something that yeah I'm like I
get why they see G did and I do again I go back
and forth because some of the things especially
with the tentacles in the eyes it's like you can
get Reflections and textures and things that you
can't in the same way as animation and I do
appreciate that they kind of use lighting and
shading and Line work to make it look as if it's
kind of in that style of hand-drawn but I feel
like it often Falls somewhere in the middle and
I can't exactly tell why if that's like literally
the design choice or if it's just because you your
eye knows but I did think a lot of what they did
on the train still was spectacular it definitely
reminded me of like Resident Evil Zero like being
on the train with like huge icky bio Creations
but yeah with a more philosophical angle and I
always love the way especially the big villain
the big like kizuki characters like fade off and
have these like soliloquies at the end these sort
of despairing soliloquies and there's always this
sort of compassionate but you know Melancholy
moment as they fade off and so yeah you have
that initial uh attack that Onslaught basically
saying yeah these humans are selfish and they're
going to you know want to succumb to this it'll
be easy as pie and then each of them or at least
tanjiro and uh and uh kyojiro is sort of standing
up in their own way and it's like he is so strong
he is so finely tuned and trained that you know
he doesn't wake up right away but he does have
just like Spider Sense enough to pin you know the
one girl against uh you know just kind of hold her
up there and stop the attack um and then tanjiro
like I love that he sees his reflection in water
that's his you know main technique uh I I really
enjoyed that that's kind of what helps wake him up
just a nice flourish a nice in-character flourish
um and and yeah the the ways in which then they
spread that twos initsu and and you know osuke and
they're able to just walk that you know fragile
line with the theme because then you get to lower
three or upper threes you get to Upper three and
his whole thing is like you know as he's fighting
rengoku he's like you are Elite you are one of the
best you should be immortal because think how
much better you could be like I love that touch
of him trying to persuade him trying to get him on
the team like Hey what how much more would musan
kibuchi uh uh reward me for bringing in one of the
toughest of our enemies like I loved that and the
way that it comes down to the sunrise and after
this whole philosophical debate you know kyodoro
puts up like the ultimate fight and the guy [__]
out and runs off into the woods and I mean of
course what else would he have done but uh oh man
like it's the perfect kind of like maddening end
and also too again you're like oh with this with
you know kyojiro with rangoku's help like this was
oh you know like without the sun it probably would
have been a failure or he would have probably died
anyways like what chance do we have moving
forward and that's a great builder of stakes
um so yeah man I thought this did really nicely
to bring all those things you like about Demon
Slayer all the crazy uh techniques they throw
down and the animation flourishes and again
those applying to the action sequences and and
that sense of motion and vitality and grit and
intensity uh you know the horror stuff the body
horror stuff the suspenseful stuff but also the
beautiful landscape I mean like that opening on
just trees and then this like Valley of tombstones
was like haunting and striking and I love uh
the way they portray the elements POV shots and
things like that there's really sophisticated
animation there's some lovely music as well
throughout good sound effects and whatnot um and
I mean this voice cast I think always does a great
job I always really enjoy them it's got to be
hell on a few of those characters vocal cords
um but yeah like the inhabitants of the train you
know I thought were nice and Eerie each of the you
know both of the Demons it's like the first one
is the big showy one and then the second one is
the philosophical one and I thought that fit well
like the more I think about it the more as much
as I can see how this divides up into you know
episodes of a series the more I do appreciate
this as a movie and I do think that maybe even if
it doesn't a hundred percent not feel something
like an episode it does feel pretty much like
a movie overall and again yeah just like some
of those watercolor flourishes and things like
that and some of those memories and just that
Switcheroo that sort of idea of like we get on the
train we have a bit of fun we throw down with some
demons and it's badass and cool but wait that's
not actually what we're dealing with that's not
actually what's going on in the Mugen train and uh
yeah like I really appreciated that left turn into
psychology and into the roots of these characters
and into again like a good means of establishing
you know the common themes that we explore in a
show like this or in stories like this through
uh you know Shonen and whatnot and uh yeah I'm
a very satisfied Demon Slayer fan also enjoyed
the uh rangoku is not able to expound it all
on uh Tundra's father's cockro dance but I'm
curious about that like that keeps popping up I
assume that's the guy who keeps popping up and
like giving him Mystic Guidance with like the
throat slash and everything is his dad right
um but yeah that was interesting it too was
gonna happen uh with his black so his unlucky
sword is he gonna get a new sword and and you
know then become a hospital once he doesn't have
the black sword I mean the black sword is pretty
badass guys ran off of the sword everybody got
at least a moment again as much as especially
zinitsu and enosuke and nezuko are not really
the focus here they're mostly just you know
physical supporting characters occasionally
comedic supporting characters I thought their
presence was still very much appreciated I loved
again what uh rangoku did for all of them and just
kind of witnessing and beholding his character and
sort of feeling too like they're good at giving
you the perspective uh of the putting you in Our
Hero's perspective where he is kind of larger than
life but you do look at him and you're like man
I can learn from this dude you know um so yeah
man I thought this was really really cool and
I'm curious to hear what you all thought so uh hey
leave me any of your thoughts any trivia anything
that I missed or that you want to expound upon
and uh Hey if you like this reaction you want
to see more you can check out season one over at
patreon I believe there are watch alongs where you
sync up your own copy and reaction highlights
for most if not everything of season one and
uh we will I believe be going to season two
pretty quickly after this is posted so uh yeah
come join us over there if you're interested
and um much love for now and as always cheers
Chris Wham off I wanted to do a shout out
for this video and if anybody at our patreon
embodies the spirit of the hero of this show
I'm not even sure if you watch Demon Slayer
my friend but I mean look tonjuro even in the
midst of slaying a demon is still trying to do
something good give them a moment of peace I
feel like that's how you would approach some
kind of badass mantle of like slaying you
know uh supernatural creatures or whatever
you'd still do it with a compassion in your
heart because that's just how good of a guy
you are I want to know what your element would be
I want to see what your costume will be like what
kind of Sword you have my dude and I'm happy
that we know you I'm happy that you're here
with us and I hope that you're doing well
much love buddy and uh stay safe out there